the 63rd annual grammy nominations
announced today and i recognize
just a couple of them rocky theater
going to bring us up to speed
she's back now with an update on how the
show is going to look when it airs here
in january and also
other major award shows have had to go
virtual this year as well
yeah so now the official format hasn't
been released just yet but
it's said to be very different this year
of course entertaining
but different and this is all due to
pandemic concerns
the senior music editor for variety
magazine says the 2021 grammys will
likely have to go
largely virtual and possibly include a
small socially distanced audit audience
because even a few cheers
what this is what they said is better
than silence right and besides the
nominations announcement today we also
found out that the daily shows
trevor noah who is also hilarious and
brilliant
will host the show for the very first
time the 63rd grammy awards will be held
in los angeles
on january 31st and will air live right
here on channel 8.
denise are you looking forward to
anybody um
yeah well now who used to it wasn't
alicia keys she does a different music
show but i really like when she hosts
because she plays music
and she hosts i mean you can't go wrong
but i love when they do these
interesting combinations of someone from
country music with like a rapper
you know i love that i love that as a
combination bringing cultures together
right
so i'm sure they'll do that right even
if it's virtually yeah do those cool
combinations
exactly thank you so much denise all
right thanks rocky